welcome to the stronger by science
podcast and the final episode of 2019
today's episode begins by recapping all
the ups and downs of 2019 and we
announced our podcasting plans for 2020
after that we've got some feats of
strength and we have a hot off the
presses segment discussing new research
related to the effective reps concept
and antioxidant supplementation we also
discuss some behavior change theories
that might help you or your clients make
some positive changes in 2020
finally we interview world champion
power lifter Mike to shear about all
sorts of training related topics happy
holidays Happy New Year and thank you
for listening welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast and in the
final episode for 2019 I'm joined by a
special temporary guest host named Greg
Nickels thanks for having me on thank
you for coming back I was you know it's
the end of the year I was looking back
at a lot of records and metrics and
stuff with the podcast and I realized
you made more guest co-host appearances
than any other guest co-host in 2019
actually on all of our shows which is
really I mean that's a good year for you
I am both surprised and delighted yeah I
didn't feel that way I looked back at
the numbers though and you were actually
on every episode so thank you for
joining me all year what else went well
this year for the podcast so biggest
thing is we went into this having no
idea what to expect because this was the
first in for a time the only fitness
podcast so I know if anyone would be
interested in this new medium so we
didn't really have any any concrete
goals for the podcast just just to try
to get it out and hope it was good but
we broke a million downloads in our
first year going into like September or
so it looked like we were going to be
closed but things just kept on growing
through the end of the year and we took
down that milestone it feels slightly
less good because it's not like that was
a goal we were working
Hertz but it happened and so that was
nice yeah and so I mean so for us to get
on equal playing field like equal level
with Rush Limbaugh how much do we have
to increase our downloads uh when he was
at his peak how many millions per day
was it well I mean is different because
it would be like total people tuning
into the radio yeah but I think Russia's
peak was something like 30 million
uniques per week okay which is honestly
wild it was like a fifth of the u.s.
adult population we're closed
the problem is we have these boring gray
microphones we need the golden
microphone we really do alright so we
also hit another big milestone not
necessarily the podcast but we talk
about mass a lot on the podcast so you
want to share that with our listeners I
shared the first one
okay then I'll share it you got it so
every Black Friday as we mentioned on
the podcast we do a big Black Friday
sale for mass and this year was our
biggest sale ever by far
we raised $64,000 for the American
Foundation for Suicide Prevention
really fantastic charity I'd like to
take a lot of credit for donating that
money but realistically it was all of
you guys everyone listening that that
actually did it so so thank you all
those of you who did subscribe during
that sale period that money is gonna go
to fantastic use and we are super happy
that we could kind of participate but
but you guys are the ones who put the
money up so thank you okay now on to
things that didn't go as well what went
poorly this year Greg well so we've
we've talked about the fact that we're
generally hated and despised for
conservative Christian beliefs on this
podcast many times and anti marijuana
beliefs I mean those those two things go
hand in hand right but the the general
hate that we're receiving has extended
from iTunes reviews to YouTube and has
extended from our conservative Christian
beliefs to
just our general intelligence so we're
really getting bombarded by by hate and
rancor on all sides at this point and
this one I'll admit it honestly cut me
pretty deep I didn't know if honestly I
still don't know if the show can recover
but we'll do what we can and once I read
this I think you'll see why
so it was a youtube comment left by
someone whose name is Bob Bob and I hope
you're sitting down for this because it
might hit you as hard as a listener as
it hit me Bob Bob said stronger my
stronger by morons wall and it got me
there are certain things that are off
limits yeah that you just don't touch
and I think that is that crosses several
lines it's so witty and incisive to
that's the worst part is that you know
you know you got got yeah like why type
out a whole paragraph of
well-thought-out criticism when you can
just hit someone right where it hurts
the most in in four words yeah it's the
ones that hurt the most are the ones
that are undeniably true and artfully
expressed and this one checks all the
boxes yeah so but there is a silver
lining right
we did have some updates on previous
reviews we did so we will try to pick up
the pieces after this latest shot across
the bow but as Eric said there there was
a bit of a silver lining
so we read some critical reviews on a
previous podcast and I think that
segment may have gotten back to one of
the people who left one of those reviews
because one of the people updated their
one-star review saying like these guys
suck I hate them too a three-star review
and now the text of it reads edit I
guess I picked the wrong first episode
to listen to because the hosts were
being sarcastic since I can't delete a
review I'll give it a three star
placeholder while I give this podcast a
second chance
so that's nice I will note we weren't
being sarcastic we're never sarcastic on
this podcast so I'm not really sure
where that's coming from however we do
appreciate the upgrade to a three star
review and the second-chance kind of
bittersweet though because in this whole
sarcastic accusation I'd rather be hated
for who we are than loved for who were
not so the fact that he changed it based
on the false pretense that we didn't
mean it it really it's hard to consider
that necessarily a win you know what I
mean yeah for sure
but in any case we no longer have any
interest in increasing the metrics the
whole point of this podcast is to move
from three stars to four in that for
that particular review because we know
it's fluid now we know that we have the
ability to move that needle right yeah
it's it's now a continuous variable it's
not just it's not just one number set in
stone for all of time yeah so hey kudos
for the open-mindedness even if it's
completely the wrong interpretation of
the show okay so uh 2020 gray do you
have any goals or New Year's resolutions
coming up I mean not really I'm not
really a New Year's resolution
kind of a guy I do have some I guess
like one general goal for the upcoming
year and I think that's just to kind of
be more consistent with everything one
of the things about the way our business
works is there's like pretty serious
herbs and flows to what we need to get
done on a day to day basis and at like
particular times in the month especially
like the crunch time with like trying to
get mass written and edited every month
and so I'm I'm not a I'm not someone for
whom schedule like daily schedules stick
that well and so for me to get on a good
schedule and just like you know find
like a good flow on a day to day basis
it takes a while to get into that flow
and I get knocked out of it pretty
quickly
and that happened quite a few times this
year where you know for several weeks at
a time things would be good I'd be
sleeping consistently getting
to the gym well knocking out what I
needed to then you know [ __ ] would
happen sometimes it was mass deadlines
sometimes it was travel and then it
would just take like weeks or months to
like reestablish a good schedule again
and so yeah I mean III want to work on
trying to be more consistent with what's
sticking to a schedule because even
though I'm not someone who particularly
likes structure I do think I do better
when I have more structure so I mean
that's something I'm gonna be working on
this year and then also just generally
saying no more like early on in my
career I I attribute there's some degree
of my success to just saying yes to
everything so any opportunity that came
up I would say yes to it without even
thinking about it that led to working a
lot but definitely opening more doors
for me
at this point though I'm asked to do
more than I ever have been and I think I
say yes far too much and it winds up
digging me into pretty big holes so
another I guess semi resolution is just
to be more intentional about it and lose
that knee-jerk reaction of saying yes to
everything and just trying to learn how
to say no from time to time how about
you you know for me uh I like I think it
was a good year I'm happy with what I
got done I need to get more consistent
with training getting into the gym more
to not be a total hypocrite it was one
of those things where an injury derailed
me and then it was just like oh I guess
I don't train anymore cuz I'm hurt I
think at a certain point I was like wait
a minute I don't think on that hurt
anymore and I still wasn't training much
so so I've recently gotten back into it
pretty consistently and that's a good
thing I know Eric Lee Salazar
challenging me to a bodybuilding
competition in like 2021 and I was like
oh god this isn't going to go well I
still don't know I still don't know how
I feel about that
I guess I have to become an IFBB Pro to
compete with him now right can pros not
compete in amateur shows I don't know
how the IFBB works but he's a pro now
and I have no idea I guess I guess in
2020 I guess the goal is to be an IFBB
Pro maybe that's not serious by the way
okay but yeah I also want to get more
writing done and that you you mentioned
having structure it kind of brings us to
the next thing was a small to moderate
sized announcement we get together all
the time and talk about the podcast how
things are going we're extremely happy
with how 2019 went but shifting the
focus toward 2020 we are gonna have some
little changes in terms of the structure
what we're gonna do is shift to a bio is
it bi-weekly
every other week bi-weekly has two
different possible interpretation we r
not doing twice a week yeah soso
bi-weekly could either mean twice a week
or once every other week yeah and we
mean the latter yeah so we're gonna
start releasing episodes once every
other week and what we're gonna do is
kind of consolidate the formats and
combine them so we're not gonna have
like you know just a Q&A episode every
other week permanently right so what
we're gonna do is have Q&A segments that
go into the entire episode so we're kind
of merging things back together into one
singular show format if we do interviews
there more often than not going to be
released as just additional bonuses that
just kind of sporadically kind of
happened and the reason we're doing that
we want to make sure that we're still
able to bring out different kinds of
content so you know two and a half hours
of podcasting a week is a somewhat
hellish pace if you're doing a lot of
research into the content and so in in
the interest of making sure we're always
delivering really good stuff and able to
do a lot of writing as well we're gonna
be doing every other week you're gonna
be getting the same amount of content
from us it's just not all gonna be
podcast because we look back at 2019 it
was pretty podcast heavy I think yeah I
mean the in hindsight it was one of
those things where while we were doing
it we were just like well I mean people
are listening it is fun to record these
things I enjoy
but then when you look at other
podcasters like people who put out the
amount of content we do it tends to
follow one of two different trajectories
either it's all interview podcasts so
it's not really on the hosts to pull
together you know four of those five
hours of content yeah thinking every two
weeks but you know like the vast
majority of the content or you know it's
it's people who podcast professionally
and the thing is like the way the way
we've always run the business is like we
put out a lot of free content and then
also have some paid content as well and
so like the podcast isn't monetized like
will occasionally mention stronger by
science products on it but the like
conversion rate from pitching stuff on
podcast to people buying products is
like way worse than email or social
media we haven't accepted like a sponsor
or anything so for all intents and
purposes the podcast is just free
content which is fine like that has been
our intention but we also have other
other means of putting out free content
the biggest of which is the website
which is like the cornerstone of what we
do and like Eric said the podcast by and
large cannibalize the website this year
and so you know we're we're just trying
to bring the two more back into balance
moving forward yeah so you're still
gonna be getting the same amount of
content from us it's just gonna be you
know somes gonna be written some is
gonna be audio still gonna have episodes
every other week one of the nice things
is that the podcast is essentially going
to become a highlight reel you know
we're kind of in the in the groove of
making like two or three hours of pretty
solid content a week so now we're gonna
be trying to condense that into a
hopefully not 5 hour every other week
vodcast so it probably is going to
become like a highlight reel so that's
going to be an exciting aspect to it or
I mean we didn't plan on them being two
to three hours apiece correct it very
well could just turn
to a five-hour podcast every two weeks
we're gonna no we're not we're gonna try
not to do that
well yeah so hopefully listeners
understand I mean like if we do like a
research roundup with 5 studies in it
like we just tore apart like five papers
prepping for that single segment of that
episode which we're happy to do we love
the work but I think we do need to bring
some balance back to the table so for
sure hopefully people aren't gonna light
up our our comments and give us a bunch
of mean reviews yeah so in addition to
the podcast moving from once a week to
once every two weeks again something
else we're planning on as well is kind
of like organizing it into seasons so
another another time where the podcast
did kind of put a little bit of hitch
and our giddyup this year was like
during the summer and around the
holidays so especially with trying to
get out in episode a week but just in
general during those times a lot of
conferences are during the summer and we
do get invited to speak a reasonable
amount and so you know trying to find
time to record and edit the podcast
around travel during the summer is is
pretty cumbersome and put us in some
tight spots this year and also just
around the holidays so the the week
leading up to recording this current
podcast has been just a huge piece of
[ __ ] for me but this is like the last
thing and then like you know I'll be
able to coast into Christmas and it's
kind of the opposite for Eric like he
has had a lot of work this past week but
now with us recording the podcast today
and him going to be having to edit it
he's setting himself up for a couple
pretty shitty days prior to Christmas
anyway so that's not a great way to
experience the holidays and so one of
the other things we're going to do is
basically we're going to run the pod
asked from so you're gonna hear this on
the 26th or that's when it's gonna drop
we're going to come back on January 16th
and then we're going to run it again
until like mid-april we're gonna be off
from mid-april until the end of July
we're gonna come back in August and go
from August until mid-november so we
it's not unlikely that we'll drop
something during those times we're off
maybe we'll record a cool interview
maybe there'll just be some stuff that
comes out that we're like hey we really
want to jump on the mic and talk about
this for 3045 minutes but essentially
we're gonna have like a spring season
and a fall season of the show so yeah
that's that's the plan moving forward
just so you guys know what to expect and
I don't want to hear complaints about
this because every time I get a message
from somebody on Instagram they'll be
like hey love the podcast and ask me a
question I'll be like we already covered
that they're like sorry I'm 11 episodes
behind I'm like okay you need some time
to catch up so that that's another thing
okay so let's move on to some content
we've got some the final feats of
strength of 2019 we do so just to start
with and and honestly this one's kind of
like a trick lift but for my money it
may be the feat of strength of 2019 I
just found it unbelievably impressive so
if you don't know what the Jefferson
deadlift is it's essentially doing a
deadlift where you're straddling the bar
instead of the bar being in front of
your shins and so Jefferson deadlifts
are are generally perceived to be harder
than regular deadlifts since you can get
over the bar a little bit better
it's like theoretically maybe a little
bit easier for your back but at the same
time like your spine is probably going
to be twisted so it is probably going to
be harder for one side of your back but
the biggest thing is just it's it's
pretty tough to be able to equally
distribute the load and the weight
between both of your legs so it's like
not quite a unilateral exercise
but it's certainly not like a perfectly
bilateral exercise it's just kind of
weird and I've done a fair amount of
Jefferson's and I mean for me personally
there they're quite a bit harder than
regular deadlifts
but anyway so Jefferson deadlifts
generally aren't something people go
super heavy on and maybe about a month
ago a guy named Sean green shared a
video of himself doing the Jefferson
deadlift with I think 8:05 which to my
knowledge was the biggest Jefferson
deadlift ever done and according to
people who like follow AAB lives like
that more closely than I do
they were also saying that was the
biggest Jefferson deadlift that they
were aware of anyone ever doing so
that's impressive then a guy named Steve
Johnson fired back and did 810 so that's
cool we went from you know zero
800-pound Jefferson deadlifts to two
that's pretty impressive and then Sean
green that first guy fired back again
and did a 910 pound Jefferson deadlift
which is batshit crazy
that's a no no no I lied it was 906
slightly less crazy Verve regardless
that's ridiculous and if you've never
done a Jefferson deadlift before go give
it a shot I mean doing a deadlift of any
sort with nine oh six is crazy but even
crazier for a Jefferson deadlift so that
was cool go check that out
next also on the deadlift front is Jamal
browner so we've talked about Jamal on
this podcast before he has he has posted
a lot of videos to Instagram of him
deadlifting really really heavy weight
but most of those videos were him
pulling with straps so strip straps and
sumo and that's unfortunate because like
yeah if you can pull heavy with straps
but it's conventional I
who cares about your grip you can go do
a strongman meet a lot of them allow
straps but strongman doesn't allow sumo
so like straps and sumo is just kind of
this like no-man's land where there's no
competition you can do to really show
out with that style of deadlifts and the
story I've heard from a lot of people is
basically that Jamal had grip issues
that he was doing grip work but also
training heavy deadlifts with straps so
essentially you know he could train the
muscles without his grip being a
limiting factor while also working on
grip so it would become less of a
limiting factor so like he I think he's
pulled over a thousand with straps
before which is wild and I believe he
competes at 2:42 so not like you know
not a super big guy either but anyway so
his best deadlift in meat at this point
is 865 or 390 two and a half kilos and
up until recently that was the most I'd
seen him pull without straps either he
may have gone like slightly heavier than
that but not much heavier but anyway
he's he's taken to learning hook grip
which seems to really really be helping
his grip problems so he posted a video
maybe about two weeks ago of himself
pulling 960 which yeah I should have got
that in kilos 960 is a lot of kilos what
what is that like 430 or something
whatever it's it's a [ __ ] ton of kilos
so that's like almost a hundred pounds
more than the most he's done on the
platform if memory serves from that
video he was using kilo plates like the
thin one so it wasn't like you know the
the fat plates that sometimes people use
to get a little extra whip for the gram
so you know seemed like a very very
legit deadlift
95 pounds over the best he's pulled in
competition and I mean based on what
he's pulled with straps before once he
really gets that hook grip locked in
maybe we're gonna see a thousand out of
him
unbelievably strong deadlift her though
very impressive next is also one of the
things I found more impressive this year
period
Wayne Van Nostrand benched 601 at 50
years old became the second person ever
to bench over 600 pounds so 272 and a
half kilos at 50 years old or older
he joined Lazlo Meszaros so Lazlo he's
not like her he's not really a household
name in powerlifting but he should be
very accomplished benchpress specialist
he's been doing the damn thing for 20
plus years at this point I think and at
one point I think in 2013 his bench was
top five all-time so he never quite
cracked that level of like you know
Kirill Saratov Scott Mendelssohn like
those were he was a little bit before
Kirill but yeah he was I think for a
time the best raw bencher in the world
but the people who came slightly before
him he never quite broke their records
but I mean Lazlo is a bad man so Wayne
Van Nostrand joined him as the only
other person the bench 600-plus at 50
years old or older I had never heard of
Wayne Van Nostrand before I just like
searched a picture of him to see like
what does someone who benches 600 plus
at 50 years old look like dudes [ __ ]
huge like he and it's not even light and
he has this big beard as well but it's
not one of those like swole like Santa
looking things because it is like a
greyish white beard because like he's
too unbelievably huge for someone to
even like conceive of it as like a Jack
Santa type thing dudes just [ __ ]
enormous ok so two more moving back to
deadlifts
Demitri nasa knov is another guy who
also isn't really a household name in
powerlifting but should be he is he's
for my money maybe the best deadlift on
the planet like on a
pound-for-pound basis and not like
strictly pound for pound like in terms
of any sort of reasonable fair scaling
formula but anyway Dmitriy NASA knov has
the all-time world record at 181 or
eighty two and a half kilos he's pulled
400 kilos previously which is 880 pounds
the next highest in that weight class is
John hack $7.99 or 360 two and a half so
you know not only is 400 kilos a lot of
weight for anyone it's an enormous
amount of weight for someone who's 181
and he's 80 pounds ahead of anyone else
that he's competing against so that's
wild in its own right but he recently
did not break his record but he went 3
90 kilos which is 860 pounds in a full
meet so the 400 kilos he did previously
was in a deadlift only meet for for like
an intermediate level power lifter the
difference between doing a full power
meet and like a single lifts me probably
isn't that big but for really really
elite level power lifters like squatting
a lot takes a lot out of you if you're
then also hoping to pull a world-record
deadlift um so I didn't realise how good
of a squatter NASA knob was as well so
again keeping in mind the dudes 181 he
squatted 863 with wraps which is I mean
that's an elite squat in that weight
class not quite as elite as the one
we're about to talk about but still like
that's that's a crazy number of 181 and
his second attempt squat just like
folded him in the hole and that's
another thing like if you're planning on
pulling a big deadlift if you like just
miss a squat like you miss groove it or
whatever or you can't quite grind it out
you know that could take a little bit
out of your deadlift but if you just
like get folded it didn't look good like
it looked like I like I don't think
anyone would have been surprised if he
bombed after that so second attempt
squat look looked bad he stayed in the
meat and still went on to pull 390 or
860 at the end of the meet and he he
also attempted 926 I didn't see the
video of that but I mean based on how
860 moved 926 wasn't a crazy attempt
like the 860 was still a [ __ ] speed
rep which is wild but he attempted 920
and and based on what I heard he got it
off the ground but his grip went he
posted a video or a picture to Instagram
where his hands were incredibly bloody
so I think that's what happened to him
but I mean the the things he's doing
with the deadlift in that weight class
are honestly mind-blowing and even
though he didn't break the record in
this meet he did set the record for
highest deadlift in a full-power meet
which kind of that's kind of like an
asterisk record but whatever but I
mainly just wanted to use the excuse to
talk about him because he's so
impressive and more people need to know
about the guy and then lastly I just
want to point out we called our shot
recently I talked about Mahatma Hamid
ryi see a Turkish guy posted some really
big spots to Instagram and I said within
the next year I think he's going to take
the world record in that weight class he
was previously like 13th in the weight
class but had only competed once or
twice so that that episode where we
talked about him came out on Thursday he
competed on Saturday two days later and
took the world record took down Tom
callouses squat in the 181 weight class
with raps previous record was 788 he
squatted 793 or 360 kilos so I didn't
quite break the 800-pound barrier but
came damn close and some some world
records especially in the squat are a
little
because you know maybe depth is closed
but questionable to my eye he went
convincingly deep it was a really really
solid lift so congrats to him and
congrats to us for for calling our shot
on that one you know that's the one
thing I get really annoyed about is that
no one gives us credit for finding these
just needle in the haystack
one-in-a-million type predictions that
always come true like who could have
possibly known that chase young was
gonna make the list of of Heisman
finalists if you listen to the podcast
you did no one else did yes is just
another example he was super under the
radar before that totally on my road and
people had even heard of chase Young I
think we put them on the map so like the
idea that I mean we're just getting
negative review after negative review
are people tired of winning are they
tired of being right months before
everybody else finds out well I mean
even after our scarily accurate
prediction of the FDA clarifying CBD
policy in like episode two no one has
told us any federal policies they'd like
us to see changer they'd like to see
changed or clarified that's true we have
that power
people just don't trust us that actually
the CBD space has been very interesting
in the news I don't want to get into all
the details but it is things are
happening didn't um didn't someone from
like Kentucky or like Tennessee have a
CBD store rated and shut down recently
so the FDA fairly recently sent out a
whole new batch of letters telling
people hey guys just a reminder this
isn't a supplement and then a couple
weeks a week or two ago I think someone
in Iowa had a CBD stole okay that was it
and they were arrested and charged based
on state level laws you know it was not
a federal rate or anything like that it
was state level stuff but it's it's an
evolving space it's something to keep an
eye on okay so recently we introduced a
new segment called hot off the presses
where we give a little brief discussion
about something that like literally just
came out you know
pretty-pretty news
stuff and within the last few weeks
there have been a couple new papers we
wanted to to briefly discuss and share
with our listeners so one was about
effective reps roughly they didn't
phrase it that way but yeah yeah it has
it applies to the idea of effective reps
the other one was about antioxidants and
resistance training so Greg why don't we
start off with the effective reps one
yeah so if you're if you're unaware of
or unfamiliar with the concept of
effective reps I wrote a article for
stronger by science earlier this year
that we can link so that'll be in the
show notes and we've also previously
discussed the concept on the podcast as
well so we can put a link to that time
stamp in the show notes as well but just
for a very quick recap the idea of
effective reps is essentially that for
for a rep to be effective at promoting
hypertrophy it needs to be close enough
to failure so and generally the the most
common model of effective reps that I've
seen out there is Chris Beardsley's
version and within that effective reps
model essentially the idea is that the
five reps preceding failure are going to
have enough per fiber muscle tension
enough motor unit recruitment etc to be
able to promote hypertrophy so you know
if you do a set of 10 the first five
reps the only reason you're really doing
them is to get to the last five reps and
then rep six seven eight nine and ten
all fairly equally promote a
hypertrophic response and so like a
corollary to the idea of effective reps
is that kind of in a vacuum on a per set
basis training to failure is going to be
more effective than not training to
failure a more sophisticated version
will say like well maybe not training
failure you could possibly like make a
program where
that can be beneficial because you know
training to failure
maybe it's theoretically better on a per
set basis but it might also cause more
fatigue and so maybe you can accumulate
more effective reps by saying if you
like a rapper to shy of failure so you
can do more reps you can train more
frequently etc but a very clear
implication is that if you equate stuff
like if you say we're going to do three
sets we're gonna do three sets of no
matter what training the failure should
be more effective than stopping shy of
failure so anyway with that in mind
there's a study that came out recently
from Lacerda and colleagues titled is
performing repetitions to failure less
important than volume four muscle
hypertrophy and strength so if you want
a very thorough breakdown of this paper
mics or discovered that in the issue of
mass that will be coming out January 1st
but the kind of quick and dirty version
of it is this study used a within
subject unilateral training design so
essentially they were doing knee
extensions and so one leg would perform
one program the other leg would perform
another program that's actually a really
really good model for studying
hypertrophy it's not good for strength
because you have the Cross Education
effect so that's worth keeping in mind
but but with effective reps you're
worried about hypertrophy like that's
what the model applies to so for for
hypertrophic stuff it was a really good
research model basically lets everyone
serve as their own control so you don't
have to worry about a sampling error or
anything like that and the way it was
set up is the subjects trained so like
one workout they trained one leg in a
failure condition and in the next
workout they would train the other leg
matching for reps so they were doing
three sets to start with bumped it up to
four midway through the program but if
doing three sets if the failure leg got
a total of thirty reps across those
three sets the non failure leg
or the volume matched leg would just do
three sets of ten so they would match
the total number of reps performed but
the way that shook down is the failure
leg would basically do more reps on the
first set about the same number on the
second set and on on the third set it
would be more fatiguing in fewer reps
versus basically the same number of reps
per set so the way that shook down is
that the failure leg trained either
three three or four sets to failure
whereas the non failure leg first set
had about two reps in reserve on average
the second set had about one rep and
reserve on average so nominally they
should have been doing about three fewer
effective reps per session and so when
you look at the results of this study
hypertrophy so they looked at both
rectus femoris and vastus lateralis
growth it wasn't statistically
significantly different between groups
but the nominal like non significant
differences did lean in favor of more
hypertrophy in the non failure condition
and they also did an interesting
analysis basically looking to see within
each individual when comparing their
like right leg to their left leg and
just keeping in mind the average
measurement error of the equipment they
were using basically for on an
individual basis how many individuals
had one leg grow meaningfully more than
the other like more than the measurement
error of the equipment and so for vastus
lateralis hypertrophy zero subjects had
a meaningfully experienced meaningfully
larger gains in the failure condition
failure and non failure training calls
to similar hypertrophy in six of the
subjects and in four of the subjects
there were greater gains when not
training to failure so again it's just
worth keeping a mind on a group basis
still not large enough differences to be
statistically significant but a couple
things do kind
lean in favor of non failure in this
study so that's that's worth keeping in
mind because if you go back and read the
article we wrote about it when looking
at research where you basically are
either comparing failure training to non
failure training with sets matched or
roughly matched or you're comparing to
non failure conditions where one is
training closer to failure than the
other so you know theoretically getting
in more effective reps if you look at
studies on untrained lifters you can
definitely make a case for the whole
idea of effective reps and training to
failure or closer to failure being more
effective for promoting hypertrophy on a
per set basis specifically there are two
studies that seem to show that pretty
strongly when looking at the biceps from
martorelli and colleagues and the other
looking at the quads from godo back in
like 2006 or so but then if you look at
the studies on trained lifters the stuff
that's out there just really doesn't
support the concept of the effective
reps model and especially like training
to failure closer to failure being
better for hypertrophy on a per set
basis just a nuance I'd a little bit
like obviously it matters to some degree
we talked about this the last time we
talked about effective reps there's
there's a soft version and there's a
hard version of the idea the soft
version is that essentially each set
does need to be kind of hard you know if
you can do ten reps with a particular
weight you're Alma I would say with a
hundred percent confidence you're going
to grow more on a per set basis doing
eight reps per set than two if it's a
weight you can do for ten but then the
question is like is it going to be worse
than doing ten reps with a load you can
move for ten reps and there I think the
research is a lot more equivocal and if
I if I was a betting man I don't know if
I would bet that one of those two would
be better so that's kind of like the
soft version of the idea the hard
version of the idea is that yes doing 10
reps with a 10 rep max load is going to
promote
meaningfully more growth on a per side
basis than doing eight reps with a 10
rep max load and so I think that the
harder version of the effect of reps
concept does have less support so like I
said it did have some support with
untrained lifters and less with trained
lifters this was another study on
untrained lifter so that that calls the
concept into question even more because
that that is the population for which it
had more support in the first place so
yeah I think that's about all I got for
that study yeah especially you know
we've talked at great length about
effective reps previously which we will
go ahead and link that in the show notes
now another thing that came out recently
this has been a really active area of
research specifically on the review side
of things so it's long been thought and
kind of we've mentioned on the show that
the kind of prevailing theory is that
high dose antioxidants particularly
vitamin C with or without vitamin E
blunts training adaptations and the
where this idea started was more in the
endurance training side of things with a
few studies showing hey this kind of
blunted some training adaptations we
thought it would be beneficial you know
because it would reduce muscle damage
facilitate recovery reduce oxidative
stress all that stuff so it started on
the endurance side of things there were
some individual studies coming out
indicating hey this might blunt anabolic
signaling if you do a really high dose
of vitamin C before training
it might blunt anabolic signaling in
response to resistance training and
might potentially blunt hypertrophy and
strength gains as well so it's one of
those bodies of literature where there's
not that many really well done
individual studies but the prevailing
understanding of the literature is hey
this high dose antioxidant stuff might
be bad news might blunt training
adaptations now in the last few weeks or
at least the last couple months there
has been a big narrative review paper
that came out on the topic and there was
also a meta-analysis on the topic that
came out I mean I think just days ago
maybe a week so so it you know it's
something a person asked about it in the
mass group one of the things I find
fascinating is that the conclusions of
the narrative review and the conclusions
of the meta-analysis are divergent they
conflict with each other so this is
something we wanted to address on the
podcast so Greg antioxidants blunting
training adaptation specifically for
resistance training where are we at yeah
so like Eric said the the one of those
reviews that I was personally the most
interested in was the meta analysis
because narrative reviews are
interesting right where if someone if
someone is pretty objective and even
though it's a narrative review they they
do do a pretty systematic review of the
literature and try to get everything in
never narrative reviews can be really
good and really helpful like there are a
lot of high-quality narrative reviews
out there but narrative reviews can also
be used to essentially essentially as an
editorial to you know push an idea that
may not necessarily be super strongly
supported so on honestly I tend to not
read narrative reviews so I'm not
calling the question of the recent one
on antioxidants into question
I just haven't read it meta analyses can
also sometimes be misleading based on
inclusion criteria or I mean some meta
analyses are just really poorly done but
with stuff like that you can hopefully
at least see through it a little bit
better where if you look at the
inclusion criteria you're like oh well
this may not be appropriate or you know
may not be the best group of studies to
look at or you can look at the stats and
be like oh they just they did this wrong
if you know what to look for sorry I
tend to read most of the medes that come
out and so there was a recent one by
Clifford the title was the effects of
vitamin C and E on exercise induced
physiological adaptations : a systematic
review and
Alyce's of randomized controlled trials
and so it was looking at the effects of
vitamin C and E both of which are
antioxidants so vitamin C and E
supplementation on changes in aerobic
capacity so like vo2 max vo2 peak
aerobic performance so you know things
like like time trial performance things
like that lean body mass and strength
and so this meta-analysis was linked in
the mass group and someone was basically
saying like hey I've heard people saying
that antioxidants blunt muscle
hypertrophy this meadow was just
published so what gives and so that
actually got me to pull up the meta read
it through download all of the studies
that they used looking at resistance
training to try to dig into this to give
a good answer to the question and I
thought it would be possibly interesting
for the podcast as well and so just to
start with I'm not at all interested in
the findings on aerobic capacity aerobic
performance or strength like I've heard
people talking about antioxidant
supplementation blunting endurance
capacity like that's or endurance
adaptations to training like I know that
that's an idea that people have talked
about before it's just not what I
personally care about and I hadn't
really heard anyone saying that vitamin
C and E supplementation would blunt
strength gains so I don't really care
about that all that much either
mainly because like hypertrophy to my
view is one of the factors that
contributes to strength gains but
especially in shorter term research
neurological adaptations and just
improving technique and whatnot
especially in studies on untrained
lifters those are going to be the things
largely responsible for most of the
strength gains and so if antioxidants
blunt hypertrophy a little bit I want to
necessarily expect that to negatively
influence strength gains in the short
commader 't term in a body of research
mostly on untrained delivers so I didn't
care about aerobic capacity
performance or strength eyes erode in on
the studies looking at hypertrophy
because that's that's that's what I've
heard people talk about antioxidant
oxidant supplementation hindering and
that's that's the portion of the meta
that I personally cared about the most
and so like I said they were looking at
changes in lean body mass one of the
things we've talked about on the podcast
before is how changes and changes in
lean body mass are probably correlated
with actual muscle hypertrophy but you
have a lot of lean body mass that is not
skeletal muscle tissue and so especially
like especially if you have a study
where the only thing your training is
quads and you look at total body lean
mass you know what are you gonna add to
your quads maybe maybe a quarter kilo of
muscle mass over the course of a study
so that's really not gonna move the
needle on lean mass at all and lean mass
is just a less sensitive measure to
muscle hypertrophy than actual direct
measures of hypertrophy like changes in
muscle thicknesses cross sectional area
fiber cross sectional area so the
meta-analysis did find that vitamin C
and E supplementation did not hinder
gains and lean body mass in the studies
they looked at but I wanted to pull
those up and see how many of those
studies did actually assess changes in
muscle mass so actually looking at cross
sectional areas muscle thicknesses etc
so there were nine studies in that meta
that looked at changes in lean body mass
there were three that looked at direct
changes in muscle size so in thicknesses
cross sectional area etc and there was
one other study that I think might be
useful to podcast listeners the other
studies the other five just really
aren't worth dwelling on I don't think
so
there were two studies that were for
week-long eccentric training studies
four weeks isn't gonna four weeks is it
short for a strength study and it's
certainly too short for I for
hypertrophy study and again those two
studies were just looking at changes in
lean mass and then the other three
studies I actually think I'm not
leveling accusations here but I'm pretty
sure it was three papers from the same
study which isn't necessarily a bad
thing if you're reporting different
measures each time and they did report
some different measures each time but
there were a lot of measures that were
reported in all three papers and and I'm
quite confident it came from just one
study that was run because it was a six
month long training study and the papers
published were 2008 2010 2011 and 80% of
the measures were the same in each study
and the training program was the same in
each paper and no way in hell you're
running three six-month training studies
back to back to back with the same
training program and 80% of the same
outcome measures so I'm pretty sure that
three of the nine studies included in
this in the lean body mass portion of
the meadow were just one study
yeah and just so listeners are aware
that that's the thing that when you're
doing a meta you'd really like to
account for you don't want to put the
same result in three times obviously and
if it's all from the same study you have
to mathematically account for that so
that it's you don't want three studies
yanking your results in one direction
for the meta-analysis when it was really
just one group of people being observed
and I did notice in at least two of
those papers one was like a letter to
the editor which was didn't have a ton
of detail in it
however Kudo to Clifford and colleagues
for finding a letter to the editor with
data reported to include in a
meta-analysis yeah that is indicative of
an incredibly thorough lit search it is
yeah but in two of those three papers I
did see that for certain measures that
were overlapping the placebo group if
memory serves had the exact same sample
size and the same mean and the same
standard deviation for certain variables
so it it would appear that there is some
degree of mixing and matching
within this data set it would seem and
unless there's you know sometimes
numbers do weird things I guess but it
looks that way yeah so so regardless
those five papers the three that we're
pretty sure are just one study and the
two five week eccentric training studies
none of them looked at direct changes in
muscle size and I just don't think
they're that overly relevant in the
first place so of the studies that did
directly assess changes in muscle size
there was a 2014 study by Paulson and
colleagues a 2015 study by bjornsen and
colleagues at a 2018 study by Dutra and
colleagues and so in those studies just
taking them in order the Paulson study
took a lot of measures so it had both an
acute and chronic component and in the
acute component they found that
antioxidant antioxidant supplementation
did seem to interfere with some measures
of anabolic signaling so for example
reduced phosphorylation of p7e s6k
and a couple other like signaling
proteins within anabolic pathways
however total ubiquitin levels after the
session were lower with antioxidant
supplementation and so ubiquitin isn't a
direct measure of but it is correlated
with muscle protein breakdown like
basically proteins are ubiquity to label
them for for breakdown so some anabolic
signaling was higher with without
antioxidants but markers of protein
breakdown were also higher without
antioxidants total muscle protein
synthesis was similar both with and
without antioxidants so that's what they
found in the acute portion of the study
and probably the most relevant thing
that they looked at there was total
muscle protein synthesis means similar
between the conditions and you know that
seemed to hold for chronic training
adaptations as well they looked
changes in MRI measured hypertrophy of I
believe the quads and they also looked
at changes in fiber cross-sectional area
both type 1 and type 2 fibers and
antioxidant supplementation did not
blood hypertrophy over ten weeks so just
keep that in mind
one study taking a couple different
measures of hypertrophy antioxidant
supplementation didn't seem to
negatively affect growth so moving on to
the 2015 study by bjornsen it assessed
so it looked at several measures of lean
mass but it also looked at changes in
muscle thicknesses of the rectus femoris
the biceps and the vastus lateralis
after I believe a 12-week training
period and so in that study they found
similar muscle growth in the biceps and
vastus lateralis but significantly more
growth of the rectus femoris in the
placebo group than the antioxidant group
so again so far we have I think five
measures of like direct measures a
muscle hypertrophy across two studies
one of the five does show antioxidant
supplementation possibly blunting
hypertrophy and so the last one is a
2018 study by Dutra and colleagues it
looked at changes in muscle thickness in
the quads after a chronic training
intervention and it also didn't find
that muscle thickness increased to a
lesser degree with antioxidant
supplementation so those are the three
studies that that we have that have
directly assessed hypertrophy after
antioxidant supplementation and none of
the three found that herb of the three
there was only one measure finding that
antioxidant supplementation did blunt
hypertrophy there were like six other
measures across the three studies that
really found no meaningful effect so the
the only other study that is is possibly
relevant here which didn't directly
assess hypertrophy but
which used a train protocol that's
probably it it was like normal ass
training it wasn't just like single
joint training whatever it was a 20-19
study by Dutra and so again they didn't
they didn't look at changes in muscle
thicknesses or cross sectional area they
did just look at changes in lean mass
and fat mass what they found in this
study is that the the antioxidant group
didn't have significantly greater gains
in lean mass and significantly larger
changes in fat mass than the placebo
group but they did find that only the
placebo group had a significant increase
in lean mass and a near significant
decrease in fat mass as well so like pre
to post the games were larger in the
placebo or the games were large enough
to be significant in the placebo group
and out the antioxidant group but
between groups there wasn't quite a
large enough difference for it to be
statistically significant you can pull
up that study will have it linked in the
show notes
it's a PubMed Commons paper so it's it's
free to view for anyone you can look at
those bar graphs in the study and decide
for yourself if the difference between
groups is large enough to be potentially
relevant so anyway those are the four
studies that are probably most relevant
for the podcast listeners here and of
them really have one study with one out
of three measures saying oh well maybe
antioxidant supplementation blunts
growth you have another study the 2019
Dutra paper where depending on your
perspective
maybe antioxidant supplementation might
might blunt some gains and lean body
mass and decreases in fat mass even
though you would be perfectly justified
to also argue that it doesn't because
those differences weren't quite
significant between groups and then you
have two studies where it's just awash
in antioxidant supplementation didn't
seem to blood hypertrophy so my personal
assessment of this literature and you
are free to disagree with it is
personally I thought
that keeping in mind that this isn't
this isn't stuff that I pay super close
attention to so like I'd seen I know I'd
seen the the the bjornsen study that's
the one that people always cite because
it was the one where there is a measure
showing as a significantly smaller
increase in muscle size with vitamin C
and E supplementation so I know I'd seen
that one I know I'd seen some of the
acute studies showing that like oh maybe
this like blunts and anabolic signaling
and so my understanding of this body of
literature is that we did have
reasonably robust and consistent
evidence showing that antioxidant
supplementation blunted hypertrophy when
we actually look at the papers that are
out there though it's not a consistent
finding and the one the one paper that
did find a significant effect in one out
of three muscles the impact wasn't huge
it was a gain of like sixteen percent in
one group versus eleven and the other
group so you know it's not like we're
talking about it just completely
squelching hypertrophy and so I think I
think one I'm now probably a little I
probably care a little bit less about
antioxidant supplementation in general I
thought that it was something that did
have like a pretty large and consistent
effect with a blunting hypertrophy that
doesn't seem to be the case now that
I've actually dug into the literature so
I apologize for previously making that
recommendation in the past but what I
also will say is that if you if you just
want to take like a better safe than
sorry approach
I do think you probably still be better
off not taking high-dose antioxidants
before and around training because the
significant effects that do exist are
antioxidant supplementation blunting
growth or potentially blunting growth
unless you just have absurdly high
oxidative stress levels at baseline
you're you're probably not gonna get
anything from supplementing with
antioxidants so I it's still not
something I would recommend but I think
it's I think it probably has less of a
negative impact or no negative impact
relative to the pretty large and
consistent negative impact that I
previously thought it had yeah I mean
I'm not sure with my assessment my
conclusion is not fully formed yet
because we mentioned like a million
years ago I was gonna write an article
about antioxidants and it was a million
years ago and there's still no article
so that's a pretty fair assessment of
exactly where I'm at with it not quite
done and not super close but still
working on it so I pretty much have just
gotten to the point where I'm really
gonna dig into the whole body of
literature when it comes to does this
does this supplementation affect muscle
damage acute performance and then
chronic adaptations to different types
of exercise so I am gonna touch on a
little bit of aerobic stuff I think so
I'm not really ready to say like Oh
looks like we are wrong you know go
ahead and do a gram pre and a gram post
with your vitamin C because I kind of my
tentative conclusion is similar to yours
where I'm trying to figure out you know
so maybe the maybe the down sides have
been overstated or our confidence in
those downsides have been overstated but
I'm still not sure what the upside is if
you're not a person with a great deal of
oxidative stress at baseline and so
that's one of the things I intend to
explore in more detail in the article
which should be out hopefully within
like a reasonable timeframe I was gonna
put actual date on it but I would regret
it immediately so I I am gonna work on
pulling that thing together another
thing that I'm gonna look into is that
so a lot of this research was looking
specifically at vitamin C with or
without vitamin E the data as it
pertains to other antioxidants one of
the reasons the articles taking so long
is because there are literally thousands
of antioxidants that you could
theoretically supplement with
polyphenols as a class of supplements
don't seem to have they seem to look a
little bit more
missing as a supplement tactic then
vitamin C on its own you don't see from
the literature I've reviewed already I'm
not completely done with that lit review
the literature I've seen so far would
indicate there might be some upsides to
polyphenol supplementation wait and I
haven't seen these types of downsides
versus with vitamin C it looks like
there's less up side and higher
potential for downside even if the
downsides aren't very extreme or very
consistent so I'm still not at a point
where I'm like yes vitamin C pre and
post is a great idea but I but I am
shifting toward a it's not ideal but you
know it's probably not the end of the
world for now I kind of view it the way
I view like post exercise protein timing
it's like you know are you gonna lose
all your gains if you delay your
post-workout meal an hour or two no
you're gonna be fine but all other
things considered equal you should
probably eat after you train you know
what I mean like there's potential for
upside and no potential for downside
with that so so that's kind of where I'm
gonna leave it until I'm ready to
present that full article to the public
when you leave except in the inverse
right what's ever so you said you think
of it like post-workout protein timing
where in the case of protein timing
potential for upside no potential for
downside you're saying you think of
vitamin C and E supplementation as kind
of the inverse of that right yeah yeah I
see limited potential for upside and
reasonable potential for downside right
yeah just just trying to make sure that
that was clear on here yeah yeah so that
that's what I was getting at okay so
that does it for the hot off the presses
segment now you know we talked about you
know we're turning the page into 2020 a
lot of times people use that time to
really review their their habits and
behaviors and say like here are some
goals I want to attack in the year 2020
maybe some New Year's resolutions of how
I want to change my behaviors and habits
and so I want to talk very briefly in a
very practical sense so like this is
going to be a coaches corner segment
about behavior change okay so I always
say on the podcast once I get
outside of my area of expertise I try to
talk less and less and less and so this
is an area where I certainly wouldn't
claim to have significant expertise but
it is something you know whether you're
trying to change your own habits or
maybe you have clients and you're trying
to help them change some habits it's
certainly quite useful to know so I want
to begin with an apology to dr. Bryan
folk he taught me about behavior change
as it pertains to health habits a
million years ago when I was an
undergrad student I swear I did pay
attention at the time but I got a little
bit rusty
I didn't retain all of it so Bryan folks
actually when I had his class we chatted
he had a background in powerlifting and
and has since gotten into competitive
bodybuilding so there's maybe a 1%
chance he listens so if so hey dr. folks
but if not sorry I forgot a lot of my
health behavior stuff so for this
segment I kind of had to brush up
significantly there is a nice article I
found that's very useful and kind of
very approachable if you don't have
experience in the the area of behavior
change it's very straightforward very
concise it's I'm gonna link it in the
show notes but it's it's on the blog for
the four NASM the National Academy of
Sports Medicine little extremely minor
conflicts of interest disclosure mass
does offer CEUs for NASA but we don't
have any other relationship we don't
like get paid by them I don't have any
certifications with them so I'm not like
signing off and endorsing every single
thing they ever do and I have no
interest in necessarily promoting any of
their stuff but I just found this blog
post article that was really concise and
kind of if you're a person who's trying
to change your habits or help clients
change their habits this is really
useful stuff and what the article does
is it goes through a couple models in
terms of how we understand behavior
change basically they provide different
frameworks which are all used in the
behave like health behavior research in
terms of how do people actually go about
successfully or unsuccessfully changing
their behavior so I want to very briefly
summarize a few of these models
which are really quite helpful when you
start to think of like how am I going to
effectively change my habits or help a
client change their so the first one is
the health belief model and this model
basically focuses on how attitudes and
beliefs explain and predict behavior so
the general underlying concept of the
theory is that you typically desire to
avoid bad stuff and you generally if you
believe that you can take a specific
action to achieve the goal of avoiding
bad stuff that's likely to motivate you
to actually implement some positive
changes in your health behavior so it
suggests that the practice of engaging
in health promoting behavior is
explained by your beliefs about health
problems the perceived benefits of
actually taking action your perceived
barriers to taking that action and in
addition your self-efficacy and
self-efficacy is basically you I'm very
much oversimplifying but you believing
that you really do have the ability to
implement these changes that you're
talking about so in this particular
theory another factor is that a stimulus
or a cue to action is typically present
so usually the way they explain that in
like coursework is someone goes to the
doctor the doctor goes oh my god like
you you know your cholesterol is off the
charts that's your cue to action and so
now you believe you're you're
susceptible to this negative thing
you've got your call to action now you
believe your ability to affect that and
you're gonna start implementing changes
and the five key concepts here one is
perceives to set the susceptibility so
basically you believe or your client
believes that they are truly at risk for
some kind of negative outcome perceive
severity which means it's not just a bad
outcome it's a pretty serious bad
outcome perceived benefits would mean
you know I believe that if I do
undertake the this course of action to
address this issue I think there's going
to be something beneficial there
certainly perceived barriers are a
concept that comes up which is you know
your perception of things between you
and successfully changing that behavior
and then as I mentioned the cue to
action now this is just one of many
health health behave
your models or behavior change models it
does have some challenges or limitations
so this particular model has limited
application for people who don't
actually feel susceptible to a bad thing
or lack a cue to action so the you know
if you're trying to change your
behaviors to go from a pretty good body
builder to an exceptional body builder
this isn't really explaining what's
going on there right there's there's no
like bad thing that that's kind of
giving you a call to action of like wow
I really got to get my act together
another issue with this model is it
doesn't really consider other things
like economic stuff environmental
factors social factors and that brings
me into number two which is social
cognitive theory and the whole premise
here is that our behavior results from
continuous interactions between
ourselves the person our behavior and
our environment and so this basically
indicates that behavior is a deliberate
process where we seek positive outcomes
and avoid negative ones and like I said
one of the key factors is considering
some of these social factors
environmental factors and things like
that another factor in this model again
what you see is that self-efficacy
it is huge and it also on the topic of
social factors it acknowledges the fact
that we certainly learn from our own
experience but we also observe the
actions of others and we see the
outcomes that that come to those
individuals and we start to really shift
our own behaviors and our understanding
of behaviors based on what we see in the
environment as well another important
thing that points out is that certainly
the environment can affect a person's
behavior the environment they find
themselves in but it also acknowledges
that people can alter their of their
environment so you can actually use that
in both directions you know you might
find okay I've got some environmental
barriers that are between me and my
goals but you can also change your
environment to make it more compatible
with your goals so the idea here is that
self-efficacy is really the main
cornerstone here it's gonna influence
our outcome expectations from you know
what we expect based on what we observe
if we really change these things
self-efficacy can affect kind of our
social factors that influence our
behavior the
all can affect our goals and the whole
combination of factors really do lead
into behavior so to put it in a nutshell
obviously you know it's a big line of
research when it comes to social
cognitive theory but the idea is that
self-efficacy is absolutely critical and
our ability to actually change behavior
is going to depend on the combination of
self-efficacy what we expect in terms of
outcomes you know that the social
environment in which we find ourselves
and ultimately our goals another one I
want to mention I think this is the last
one I have here is the theory of planned
behavior and so the theory of planned
behavior is is one of the most widely
used when it comes to exercise when it
comes to these models of behavior change
the four main factors that would affect
behavior change in this model number one
is attitude so that that's just whether
or not you view performing this behavior
as positive or negative number two is
intention or our willingness to actually
do it I mentioned some subjective norms
earlier and that basically that
basically pertains to perceived social
pressures and I also mentioned perceive
behavioral control and that is the
perceived ease or difficulty when it
comes to actually performing that
behavior so you can operationally think
of it as being pretty similar to
self-efficacy and even within these
within these four main factors that that
are affecting behavior change the two
strongest ones really are in tension and
perceived behavioral control so got to
be willing to make the change and you
have to actually believe that if you do
make that change it has you know some
type of positive influence down look
down the road and so one of the
challenges is that the link obviously
between intention and behavior change is
not a perfect link you know so these
models aren't perfect they're just
frameworks for understanding how people
start to initiate behavior change and
you know one of the key challenges with
this model is that there are plenty of
people that have really good intentions
but they simply fail to carry them out
so that's why you know some of these
other models are quite helpful to use
these models aren't mutually exclusive
they're really just competing frameworks
of how we understand getting
people to make positive health changes
or changes that are more compatible with
their goals now finally there's the
transtheoretical model and this is you
know the previous three that I talked
about were really theories pertaining to
behavior change this one they
specifically say it's not a theory it's
just a framework that describes a way
that all these other theories can fit in
you can kind of mix and match them with
in this transtheoretical model and I
don't want to get too far into it but
the real take-home point of the
transtheoretical model is that there are
five stages to change and that one of
the really key things when it comes to
inducing positive behavior change and
switching your behaviors to make them
more compatible with your goals one of
the key things is making sure that
you're actually in a place where you are
ready to begin that change so there's
these five stages the first is pre
contemplation and that basically means
within the next six months or longer you
have no intention to actually change
your behavior next is the contemplation
stage which means you or your client
wants to change your behavior within the
next six months but you haven't acted on
it yet the next stage is preparation
which means within the next 30 days you
or your client really do intend to make
that change the fourth step is the
action stage and that basically means
you or your client within the past 30
days did begin initiating that
particular behavior change and then
finally its maintenance and that means
you've been maintaining this change for
more than six months now some people
they put in the relapse stage as part of
the stages I'm gonna be optimistic and
positive and say yeah relapse happens
but maybe let's not plan on it being a
critical part but one of the really cool
things about this particular model is
that it does at least acknowledge the
fact that progressing through these
stages is cyclical it's not linear and
it's not a one-way thing you know you
can go forward and backward between
these steps sometimes you you get
through the action phase you are in the
maintenance phase and you have a relapse
and you find yourself at an earlier
stage within this cyclical process and
what's nice about that is you didn't
like try a thing and lose you made your
way five steps up through these these
different stages and you
maybe you fell back - but but you're
still within this cycle of these stages
of change and you can still go back to
the drawing board reinitiate some of
those changes and get back to that
maintenance phase that we would like to
be in so those are a few theories or
models about how academics study
changing health behavior so if you or
your clients are thinking okay it's the
new year it's time to really change
things up these are good frameworks to
get you thinking about what are some of
the aspects of the environment or when
we talk about these goals are we framing
them in a way that actually is conducive
to helping somebody change their
behaviors and reach their goals and if
you look at all of these in totality
there are some overarching themes number
one self-efficacy is enormous okay so we
need to really first of all understand
that there's a relationship between this
behavior we're changing in our goal and
then secondly we need to really believe
that that we have the ability to make
that happen
number two you've got to consider
environmental and social factors that
can facilitate or hinder your progress
and along those lines you have to
recognize that our environment
influences us but we can also change our
environment to some degree to make it
more conducive so getting back to those
overarching themes like I said
self-efficacy is huge you have to
consider environmental and social
factors and how you can influence those
how they can influence you
in addition generally speaking people
really need to be ready to change before
they effectively do make changes and
then finally behavior change is cyclical
not linear so there there are relapses
that tend to happen but that doesn't
mean you're all the way back to square
one it just means you went from you know
the most advanced stage to a slightly
less advanced stage but you know you
don't have to implode the whole thing
and start over okay now that that's a
good transition we are about out of time
this week so to play us out we have one
parting message for for 2019 so not to
get preachy but you know there are going
to be a lot of people entering the gym
that that are strangers to the gym when
January comes around I I don't know if
this is an international
but I know in the United States for sure
New Year's resolutions are big the gym
gym attendance tends to absolutely
skyrocket in the month of January and
most importantly the people that are
kind of flooding into the gyms around
this time of year are gonna be people
that are less familiar with the gym less
comfortable in the gym maybe a little
bit they feel a little bit out of place
potentially a little bit intimidated so
I remember back in the day when I was
just kind of a turd and I'd be like oh
this sucks the gym used to be empty now
there's a bunch of people you know this
is my turf and now there are people who
don't belong invading it that's just a
really horrible way to think about it
so when you go to the gym and you see
there's all these people and you have to
wait a little longer for a squat rack or
whatever the case is just remember you
know be nice to people out there be
encouraging be welcoming especially if
there are people in your network your
friends and family that are just getting
into fitness just remember you know be
supportive and they don't have to start
with like the optimal perfect approach
okay all they need to do is have
motivation excitement and the intention
to do it so like I know it's really easy
when you get into the whole
evidence-based circle of things in
Fitness it's really easy when someone
does something that's like 93 percent
optimal to be like ah idiot here's how
you get up to 100 I know and like just
just recognize that that that has a
sometimes it's perceived as being
helpful sometimes it just really tears
people down and makes them have a
generally like less enjoyable experience
when they're trying to branch out and
get into this stuff and the last thing
they need is second-guessing themselves
and if you nitpick every part of their
plan that's gonna make them second-guess
themselves yeah so the thing I usually
use is my guiding principle with this
kind of thing is I never shoot down
things if they if they do no harm they
cost very little you know just because
they're not necessary or they're not
like a hundred percent ideal and optimal
just you know if it's something that
does no harm it's not costing them
anything it's not a huge financial
investment or labor investment just let
them enjoy their excitement for the gym
they're not doing any harm and
eventually once they're really into it
and they seek out additional guidance
and structure that's where you'd say hey
I noticed you do this since you asked
you could probably have a much more
enjoyable workout if you did this
instead or you might be achieving your
goals more rapidly if you did this
instead of that so you know be
supportive be encouraging don't tear
people down because they're only 85%
correct with their approach people will
generally approach you as long as you
let them know that you are available to
offer support and help but you know
don't overstep that don't start
micromanaging people and in like Greg
said don't start making them
second-guess themselves the biggest step
is just having the motivation having the
excitement and enjoying the initial
stages of the process and everything
else from there tends to tends to grow
okay so I think that does it for our
final episode of 2019 on the other side
of the music we have a fantastic inner
interview with Mike to sheer talk up
Mike Mike is reactive training systems
right he's he's got to have like a world
championship at some point right yeah
he's he's one IPF world's multiple times
when the world games easily one of the
most successful IPF coaches currently
and in history like I don't think he's
overtaken Shaco when it comes to like
pumping out medalists but they they have
a metal Factory
over there at RTS like their athletes
like win Nationals when 'world's plays
highly all the time really really bright
guy really good coach has had a
incredible lifting career in his own
right he's the type of guy that if
you're not if you don't listen to him
and pay attention to him I think less of
you as a person like Mike's Mike's the
[ __ ] man yeah I mean I first met him
this past year at the European
powerlifting conference you guys were
chatting in like the hotel lobby and it
was really fascinating to just hang
around and listen to him talk training I
think I think people are really going to
enjoy the the interview so it's a great
way to end the year as Greg said way
earlier about an hour and a half ago we
will see everyone
in I think it was January 16th we return
I believe so yeah so we'll be coming
back January 16th with our new format
we're excited we hope you will join us
take care and have a great new year
[Music]
[Music]
all right Mike to shear thank you for
coming on thanks Pam glad to be here
how's life good good I feel like I've
been running around all over the world
a little bit I have but I'm back home
now and and trying to get my kids over
jet lag which is sounds so running
around the world mostly for powerlifting
meet sir has has there been anything
else other than IPF worlds well yeah so
the big thing well I guess there was the
US Nationals but after that there was an
airborne sorry yeah they kind of there's
a bunch of them right
my wife's in the Air Force so
occasionally we'll have something go on
for that as well and since I'm mobile if
we can kind of keep the family together
then we'd like to do that so I in this
case it was we had a thing in Alabama
for a couple weeks and yeah good deal
man
so your your lifters I think I saw on
Instagram between single lift and and
just like overall one something like 11
gold medals and close to like 2025 total
medals right nationals so I'm not sure
what we did at Nationals but we usually
have a pretty pretty good time at Worlds
which would have been in in June so
that's probably the one that we were
talking about but uh yeah yeah we have
had a pretty good time this year some
unexpected high performances you know
and that's kind of one of the
interesting things I think about like
actually showing up and going through
the whole competitive experience you
know sometimes things don't go exactly
the way that you would expect on paper
and a well-executed game plan can make
the difference you know so
we were able to put some people on the
podium that we didn't really expect to
be there at first but that's always fun
that's a lot of fun when that happens
was that more than hitting bigger
numbers than you thought they would hit
or their competitors not performing
quite the way you anticipated they would
so a little bit of both probably more
often than not if someone else makes a
mistake you avoiding mistakes is kind of
how how those things shake out you know
we have a pretty good idea of the
lifters top end when they show up and I
would say it's pretty uncommon for them
to to just totally blow that away and do
something unexpected on meet day I think
it's more common that you end up dialing
things down but that's because you're
adjusting those expectations you know up
to just a couple days before the meet a
lot of times mm-hmm so usually it's
someone else's error and and it's like
oh well we can capitalize on this by not
making mistakes and and you might play
the attempt selection to an F kilos more
conservative than you otherwise would
just to make things a little bit more of
a sure thing or you know there's
different ways to to to get into the the
strategy of it you know actually avi
Silverberg did a really great job this
year during the world championship of
kind of going through the play-by-play
and it's kind of like powerlifting like
the nerdiest kind of powerlifting I
think because like where the strategy
really comes into play in the
gamesmanship it's only really relevant
if the competition is is rather tight
and most of the time that's only
happening at you know the the really
high level meets you know US Nationals
it'll it'll happen occasionally
and then at Worlds it seems to happen
quite often and it can actually be
pretty fun to watch you
you know what you're looking for so what
are what what are some examples of that
just so just so the listeners are kind
of on the same page here
gotcha yeah so I would say the where
strategy comes into play the most in in
a powerlifting meet is definitely around
the deadlift for the squat and the bench
you're just trying to build your total
you know make all three squats get as
close as you can to your to your maxes
you know but when it comes to the to the
deadlift you can be looking at other
competitors you'll know what you need to
pull to move into second place or two if
you're already in second place maybe
you're defending against somebody else
who's trying to surpass you things
matter
like what order are you pulling in you
know the person with the bigger deadlift
has an advantage because they get to
pull last so you know exactly what you
need to pull things like changing your
third attempt deadlift and knowing the
rules around that they matter knowing
exactly what you need to to put on the
bar to you know go for a win or go for a
podium spot that that's a big deal and
that's also kind of where coaching gets
to be really stressful to a lot of times
you'll see coaches back there furiously
doing math and you know doing these
calculations to try to figure out okay
if this person makes their third
deadlift then we'll need this but I
expect them to put in a change and
they'll probably change it to that in
which case we'll need to put in our
change of our own you know and you're
trying to anticipate these things
because it's all happening rather
quickly so I say it's it's like the
nerdy is kind of powerlifting coaching
because it's like fast math problems and
with a bit of anticipation of well they
they called for a 10 kilo jump and I
don't think they've got it you know so
we're gonna we're gonna play it a little
bit safer and really if you have a
smaller deadlift so you don't have the
advantage of pulling last then it's a
it's a lot more stressful
I would say because now you've got a
guess at what the other person can pull
and and you've got to push them as far
as you can you know yeah so that's
that's fun it only happens occasionally
but when it happens it's it's a lot of
fun I got you the that makes a lot of
sense so we we've gotten a little bit
ahead of ourselves
so just I I assume most people listening
to this know who you are but for the the
handful of poor souls who don't just
introduce us to Mike to sheer how did
you get started in the sport of power
lifting what's your background
why should certainly anyone who's
interested in powerlifting know about
you and your work I got started in
powerlifting when I started lifting
weights for football when I was in high
school and I would say I was interested
in lifting weights even before that but
that's when most American boys at least
start to to get into it more seriously
and this also happened to be kind of the
early days of the internet and I
remember typing in powerlifting calm
because powerlifting was just a word I
had heard sometimes I don't I didn't
even know what it was and then
discovered oh it's a sport it consists
of squat bench and deadlift oh wait you
can do training that's less than five
reps I had no idea you know and and I
just really self-taught from the
beginning even even as a freshman in
high school I remember showing up to the
first day of like football weightlifting
you know and and walking up to the coach
and doing like coach I wrote my own
program you know and I hands in this
concoction with what I mean what does
the high school freshman come up with
you know that has no access to
information other than like muscle
magazines you know and I hand him these
like things that I had printed out and
thankfully he looked at it and
and I guess was just like hey here's a
kid who's enthusiastic about lifting
weights go with it you know and he let
me do my thing and I had a blast I was
good at it I got stronger and it kind of
took off from there and like that was
you know the early times when I got into
I went to the Air Force Academy for
college and they had a powerlifting club
I pretty quickly took over being the
cadet in charge of the powerlifting club
was kind of the de-facto coach I was
writing training and whatnot for the
other members of the club and you know
going to meets rapid knees and you know
this was equipped lifting and also
competing myself and that's why I won my
first Junior World Championship in 2006
after I left I learned a lot as a coach
of that club team and something that
people were saying a lot back then was
that you have to learn how to listen to
your body this is the thing that you
just have to do if you want to train
like an advanced lifter all the advanced
lifters do it okay great how do I do
that
well nobody can tell you it just takes
like 10 years and you just figure it out
and I thought well that's a really
terrible answer you know so I started
just being very observant of the things
that I was experiencing as a lifter
because I was nearing that kind of 10
years of barbell experience timeframe
myself and oh by the way literally never
stopped reading about lifting weights
you know anything that I could get my
hands on whether it was books or
articles or you know websites whatever
you know I was reading constantly and
something that people were talking about
and this would have been like gym
Windler timeframe when 531 and
and whatnot was just starting to get
really popular and Jim was still working
for lead FTS a lot of people were
talking about leaving a rep in the tank
you know and it's it's funny now because
you talk to lifters and and it's such a
different experience but leaving a rep
in the tank was like a landmark concept
to to most guys who lifted weights like
what do you mean you stop before you
can't do anymore like I don't know how
to do that you know so it was like this
concept of lever rep in the tank and
this was also during a time frame when
the book super training was held up as
like the training Bible and and I was
trying to penetrate that impenetrable
work but my hot take on super training
is that it's very appropriate to call it
the training Bible because much like the
Bible everyone says it's their favorite
book but no one's actually read it and
like and you can different
interpretations of exactly yeah yeah I
mean I I can think of hundreds of people
that put super training unlike the top
of their oh if you're into training you
need to read this book recommendation
list but vanishingly few people who ever
actually like pull out quotes or
information from super training to put
in articles and I think that that's very
telling yeah yeah that's a really good
point actually and I mean I've called
people out on it occasionally like oh
really you've read super training and
more often than not they double down
like oh yeah yeah I read it I'm like you
don't read it you can't like you could
study it and you could like go section
by section line by line in some cases
and try to clean something from it but
it's it's I don't know is it's funny how
things have changed because information
now is just so much more accessible you
know mm-hmm can I ask a question so I've
never even pretended to read to
straining what makes it so like you said
you don't read it what does that mean
well it's I guess it's just like a text
you know like you you wouldn't you
wouldn't read a you wouldn't read it
like you would read most books on
training where well I here's page one
let me start there and just go through
it and I think you would you would
suffer some sort of health event you
know with just trying to do that but
it's it's very dense and it's not it's
only like loosely tied together I would
say it's not like a narrative format
where it's it's building an argument
from the beginning through the middle to
the end it's yeah it's constructed like
a text okay that makes sense
yeah well the the thing I came across
from super training that I thought was
useful was a discussion on our PE rate
of perceived exertion and and how the
the Borg scale worked which I thought
hey that's really interesting you know I
wonder how that applies to lifting
weights and just kind of put together
these two concepts where people were
talking about leave a rep in the tank
and this concept of grading your your
effort and I thought well you know you
could leave one rep in the tank or two
three four you know if you ain't first
you're last and and that's kind of where
the original RPE chart that that I
started talking about and teaching came
from and that I would say really started
taking off in the 2008 timeframe and
since then I continue to compete until
just a couple years ago and and did
quite well went to a lot of world
championships and I won the world games
in 2009 but ever since 2008 I would say
I've become gradually more and more
coach you know and at this point for the
last several years it's been almost
entirely coach you know I'm still
lifting weights but uh I've stepped back
from competing myself that makes sense
so
other than winning the world games which
I assume you would list that as your
biggest accomplishment as an athlete
what are what are some of the things
you've done in the sport that you're the
most proud of and just so our listeners
know what are some of your biggest lifts
both raw and single-ply let's see in
single ply that's where I started my
best squat was 903 pounds my best bench
was 633 pounds and I never competed
equipped in the deadlift I never got
anything out of deadlift suits so my
best dead lifting competition was 843
pounds and then my other raw my Ross
squat was 785 or so my best raw bench
was 480 pounds yeah which believe it or
not used to be a good bench press but
then it's like everyone else figured out
how to bench man but yeah yeah it's
definitely most well-known for for my
deadlift deadlifting like you said other
than world games I would say pulling 843
was definitely one of the highlights
that makes sense so okay let's get into
let's get into some of the concepts that
you're most well-known for these days so
you mentioned your use of the reps and
reserve based RPE scale I think that's
still probably the first thing that
comes to mind for people when they think
mike de sheer and reactive training
systems so I'm curious just in general
because you know you see how ideas catch
on and then morph and then people start
going their own ways with them what are
your or have there been any like
applications or uses of your RPE concept
that you didn't foresee when you put it
out into the world and has a kind of
been a double-edged sword in some way
like people kind of putting your name on
ideas or concepts which you personally
wanted support
yeah I mean I didn't expect it to become
the mean that it has been to be honest
you know like it I don't think it's a
bad thing at all like I think it's kind
of funny kind of cool actually but I
definitely didn't foresee that happening
and then as far as like training ideas I
suppose not really because I don't try
to lay claim to the to the idea you know
like I don't really think RPE is mine
you know although I've I've gotten into
some conversations where people kind of
make that assumption they they act as if
anyone using an RPE program is using an
RTS program my program you know and
that's not the same thing like it's a
concept that's seen much much wider
adoption than then just little me you
know so I mean I do see training
practices that make use of the concept
that I think are kind of I guess in
error you know like I looted earlier to
the idea of leaving a rep in the tank
was kind of a new idea for a lot of
people at the time what this would have
been early 2000s at least in kind of the
online circles that I was in it seemed
like a new idea to a lot of people
people were constantly being told that
they they need to you know back off the
effort you know they would recover
better and whatnot but now it seems like
things are very different from that
especially in powerlifting training it's
pretty common to see people training at
very sub maximum RPS and I've coached a
number of lifters you know more recently
who who do have recovery issues if we go
into what I would have normally
considered like a moderate RPE range
like eight you know nine eight nine RPE
I don't think is is all that crazy you
know and I get questions a lot like how
would you expect to recover from you
know multiple multiple amrap sets a week
well an AMRAP sets a ten RPE set you
know maybe you're leaving the reps
open-ended but it's one set you know
it's only a problem if you know maybe if
the program is not designed to support
it or something like that like I could
see where it would be a problem but it
seems like now we've it's more common to
come in contact with this mindset where
oh I did a 10 hour PE set I should be
wrecked for a week which is funny
because again go back to the early 2000s
it wasn't ten RPE sets it was 90%
intensities you know oh I touched a 90
percent wait I'm gonna be demolished for
a week you know people don't think that
as much anymore but it's like the high
RPE work you know have you do you see
similar things no I I definitely do and
it it makes me laugh cuz people like oh
you did at NRP set probably gonna be
wrecked for a few days it's like nah
dude like that's just what we used to
call training we used to do a dozen of
those in a workout and train two days
later like it's just how things were
yeah it didn't know any better right
yeah yeah exactly
like I mean the the idea of like if you
are leaving around so like I remember
when that got popular and it was kind of
one of those things where like unless
you're doing like dynamic effort method
like Westside style that was like the
only time it was even justified to leave
reps in the tank so like I remember
needing to be sold on leaving a rep in
the tank for any set ever but yeah so
it's completely different now
I'm just I'm just curious to what degree
do you think that that's
kind of the result of how people train
in to what degree do you think it's like
just expectancy effects so you know like
do you think people like legitimately
could recover from Rp 9/10 work be just
fine
but it's all in their head or do you
think it's just like they've always
trained with such submaximal RP s it is
just physiologically wrecking them like
obviously it's probably some degree of
both which which do you think just from
working with a lot of athletes which do
you think is like the main driver there
I've got to think that a lot of it is
expectancy and I don't know how we could
separate like what component of it is is
because of belief and what component of
it would be there even even without that
belief structure around I'm not sure how
to separate those things but I certainly
hope that it's malleable because I I
think you get locked in to such a narrow
training paradigm if you can't ever
reach into those you know eight nine ten
RPE zones like what do you what do you
do training wise so you're rather
restricted you know you're gonna be
doing lots of volume at submaximal
efforts and where do you go from there
you know you have to continue to crank
up the volume and then what you know at
least if you can reach into those higher
RPE sets it it can remake type training
can remain time efficient for a lot
longer you know and even if there's
nothing physiological that happens which
I just can't I can't get behind the idea
that there's just no difference you know
if you if you matched volume between
people who were training at really low
RPS and people were training at
hierarchies
it would just be the same I've seen
people over time of course and sometimes
it's a long period of time but
be capable of of grinding out weights
better you know you'll watch somebody do
a maximum attempt and you can chalk it
up probably as something like a motor
learning thing you know if you're not
prepared mentally to to fight with the
weight then you know you're just gonna
fail quickly right whereas if you're
prepared for it then you can grind
through it and maybe finish a lift that
you wouldn't have otherwise been able to
finish and I think training at higher
rpm for those things so it's just it
seems really limited to me to just not
even have that in the arsenal no I got
you so with that in mind and also kind
of circling back to the idea of how
things have changed over time something
that I've been I guess like stewing on
I don't think saying worried about would
be the right way to phrase it but
something that's just kind of been in
the back of my mind is do you think that
maybe newer lifters these days are
better at using our P's because it's a
concept they've you know kind of grown
up with and come up in the sport with or
do you think that they're possibly worse
at using RPS then maybe you know folks
just learning about it five years ago or
eight years ago would have been simply
because they don't have that prior
experience of going to failure and
really knowing what one or two reps shy
of failure feels like so do you think
just generally like when people are
exposed to the concept or maybe start
working with you or one of your coaches
do you find that they're getting better
at using RPE than maybe they were a few
years ago or are they struggling more so
I would really I wish I could tap you
know somebody like Ross or Jim and ask
them because they onboard a lot more a
lot more clients than I do these days so
my sample is gonna be really biased I
think what I see is that it looks like
people are generally fairly competent at
using this I mean outside of of obvious
jokes because there's there's plenty of
our PE jokes which is weird for its own
reasons our head but it seems like
people are fairly competent at using the
scale although again you know the people
that I'm focused on it's probably not a
representative sample you know so I wish
I could ask Ross or Jim about it you
know because they're gonna have probably
a different perspective than I would I
know that they've mentioned to me
needing to kind of correct people on our
PE where I tend to not have to do that
very much you know like well hey look I
know you said that was a nine but it
really looked like a seven you know and
it you you do see both types you see
some people who are dramatically
underrating but you also see plenty of
people who are pretty dramatically
overrating some yeah yeah that I think
you could probably argue it either way I
mean my experience has has been you know
like I said but ya know fair enough
so alright just kind of shifting gears a
little bit something else that you're
becoming more well known for concept you
put out I think a couple years ago at
this point is emergent strategies I
don't think this has gotten quite as
much reach as reps and reserve base RPE
has so just to kind of fill our audience
and on it what is what is like the
concept in the basic practice of using
emergent strategies so the intent goes
back to individualizing training
programs we have this sense that you
need to do the you would like to do the
very best training program that you
could that's that's custom-built for you
and you know your unique
injury history or training history your
capabilities and leverages and strengths
and weaknesses and technique and all
these things and I know for me for so
long it was a thing that I did that I
you know tried to do to build these
custom training programs custom
approaches but it didn't really have any
sort of method for it it was just that
seems right you know it was it was kind
of an eye balling sort of effect and I
think a lot of coaches do fine with that
approach it just didn't sit well enough
with me like I wanted to know I wanted
to be more sure that the things I was
observing were actually real and not
just you know not just the flavor of the
moment not just an artifact from you
know some other client or you know
there's all these different cognitive
biases and coaches have those too so how
do you how do you deal with this how do
you know that what I'm how do I know as
a coach what that what I'm giving to my
athlete is the best training program
that I can and emerging strategies is is
really a framework for building training
that helps you to hone in on what that
ideal training program will be I've
arrived at completely different training
concepts for athletes just based on what
they've responded well to so I suppose I
should kind of lay out in general how it
works just kind of the brief version of
how it works
so what we want to do is to create a
testing process that lets us try out
different training ideas and see in as
clear way as possible what's working and
what's not and what I've noticed is that
in a lot of traditional programs there
are a lot of variables that change each
week maybe the reps change this is a
high-volume week that's a low
volume week here's a here's a super
high-volume week and exercises are
rotating in and out intensity is waving
and so on and there's so much going on
at any given time that it's impossible
to really tell what's having which
effect and I also don't really think
that it's necessary to have all those
changes happening all at the same time
that if you were to give an athlete just
one week of training and have them
repeat it then they're going to have
some sort of response to that and
ideally I think if it's a
well-constructed training week they'll
get better and that's good you know and
if you can just monitor that for a
little while you're gonna learn
something and I mean I've learned all
kinds of different things I've
counterintuitive things I've found
lifters that just don't respond well to
high intensity which you know power
lifters tend to peak with high intensity
work so what do you do if high intensity
never makes you stronger and it always
makes you feel bad well maybe you should
not do that you know and I can tell you
that I've worked with lifters for years
and when we started using an emerging
strategies approach I know I learned
things about them that I didn't know
before and that said a lot to me
personally and and those things resulted
in in them going to meets and setting
PRS you know and that's that's what it's
about you know so I think the the
general recommendations do work for most
people most of the time and that serves
as a great starting point and and it's a
fine way to go for a lot of people but
if you're one of the individuals who
responds to something strange something
just not even strange but just something
not totally Orthodox then that gets to
be really important for you to know and
between all the different variables for
all the different lifts that you're
doing there's no way that everybody is
that anybody really is responding in a
totally Orthodox way to everything all
the time you know there's something
that's different
oh you would get a little bit more out
of doing paws squats versus versus pin
squats or vice versa you know and you
can inject a huge number of different
strategies into this kind of framework
we've had lifters come up with programs
and kind of evolve into programs that
look somewhat like oh like a Westside
type program we've had other lifters
that develop in a way that you know it
looks more like an orthodox program that
is popular in powerlifting now where you
have fairly high frequency of the
competition lifts and then other lifters
respond the things that are things that
are strange to powerlifting training in
general I got posted about today Greg
and this was so we developed this
strategy or really one of one of our
coaches John Garvin Oh developed a
strategy that was based off of an idea
that we heard you talk about I believe
it was in Mass about some motor learning
research about pairing pairing different
exercises together and and I mean you
would be a lot more capable of speaking
intelligently on that than that I would
be but where we went with this idea was
pairing the competition lift with an
assistance exercise that's designed to
teach something specific like oh you've
got a problem with your chest falling in
the squat so we're gonna pair the
competition squat with a pin squat and
and see if that has a positive effect
you know and and if it does then you
follow the trail of athlete response so
it's kind of a long monologue too to get
at this but hopefully I kind of lays out
some of the basics so I I think I think
all of that makes a lot of sense from a
conceptual perspective but like in terms
of in terms of like the brass tacks of
it how would you go about like you know
coming up with new ideas to test testing
those ideas and evaluating kind of what
variables
the given lifter responds best to like
what does the actual implementation of
the emerging strategies idea look like
so let's say that a new lifter signs up
and I'm going to be coaching them the
first thing I would do is talk to them
get get an idea of their history
what if they liked what do they not
liked maybe responded well to and not
and kind of where do they want to go
from here and let's assume that we've
got plenty of time to work with as well
we would come up with a with a training
program that seems plausible that
hopefully they're excited about and
think of it like a training week and
usually it is a training week although
that can that can vary but it's it's one
week and you're gonna repeat that week
every week for a while and I mean the
same exercises the same reps same sets
and the same RPE and that's an important
distinction so the the weight on the bar
is going to change a little bit so that
you can match the RPE
the idea is that I want you to get the
same stimulus each week and hopefully
you know you're doing this training
you're getting stronger so we'll need to
increase the weight on the bar a little
bit to compensate for that additional
strength gain and that can help
perpetuate the the strength gains moving
forward so it's the same week you know
each week and we're going to repeat that
training week and monitor your response
and what we see is is one of a couple
things there's there's three things
three responses that we normally see
some lifters just get better so week two
is better than week one week three is
better than week two and so on
other lifters see a performance dip in
week two followed by a steady
improvement from week three onward and
other lifters see kind of a stagnation
from week one too whenever you know no
real noticeable performance increase or
decrease and then there's kind of a big
jump toward the end it's
point there needs to be a performance
improvement otherwise I would consider
that a failed cycle a failed development
block but there needs to be a
performance improvement and there
usually is so there's a performance
improvement but that doesn't last
forever and let's take the the first
response case the case of the person
that just steadily improves each week
just because that's a little easier to
conceptualize so you do week one and
then you do week two the weights are a
little bit heavier than week three you
improve a little a little bit more and
you keep going you don't improve forever
at some point you peak and that peak is
is followed by a regression and strength
M for the first development block when
we see that regression and strength will
usually let it go so that we see two
weeks in a row of some sort of
regression and that kind of concludes
the first development block and we look
at the time that it took from the first
week to the peak week and we say that's
your time to peak for some lifters
that's going to be three weeks other
lifters it might be eight or ten weeks
it varies I would say the average is
five to six although there are plenty
outside of that average number and it
does seem to be fairly stable meaning
that if I give you a different
development cycle different exercises
different intensities as long as the
workload isn't weirdly different it'll
still be around that same time to peak
and that's really useful when it comes
time to plan for peaking competitions
and things like that from the end of
your first development block you'll go
into what we call a pivot block and you
can think of that like a D load it's a
little bit more than a D load but the
idea is to reduce the training stress
restore something like sensitivity to
training you you're feeling better and
you're ready to train again there's a
little bit of a performance decrease but
you do try to maintain strength insofar
as it as you're able to
you know while reducing fatigue and
things like that and then at the end of
that pivot block you start a new
development block and the the new
development block is different from the
first one it'll be a different intensity
different exercise selection and so on
and over time you well I should say at
the end of each development block you
should do a block review where you look
at what did you do and what results did
it have okay well in this block we
trained competition squats for triples
and then we did pin squats and then we
did leg press and that had you know a
net gain of 20 pounds on my squat you
know not necessarily a 20 pound PR but
20 pounds of improvement from week 1 to
week 6 and I'm just kind of making these
numbers up as I go but hopefully it
serves as an example and then you do
that again the block review for the
second block and a third block and so on
so when it's time for you to go to a
competition you look at all these block
reviews and and you basically replay
your greatest hits you say ok I noticed
that all the blocks where I have a
really good response in my squat I'm
doing kind of medium intensity
competition squatting and some kind of
single leg work ok that's interesting
you know so why I don't know and why is
an interesting question but when it
comes time to plan your last block you
go with what you know and what you know
at this point is that those things are
correlated more than anything else with
a high performance in your squat so
that's kind of how we build build the
epistemology around peeking into
competitions that makes sense so how how
stable do you find like the responses to
a certain type of training so if you
find what a
a good-looking developmental block looks
like now how much confidence can you
have in that still being a pretty good
developmental block say three months
from now or two years from now the more
I look at this the more those things
seem to be moderately stable two years I
don't know about two years but three
months I can be reasonably sure it's not
foolproof you know there there are
occasions where it'll it will miss but
it's also one of those things where I
think it's the best information that
I've got you know and even if it misses
what else would I have done I'm not so
sure because anything else at that point
with what I knew at the time would have
been a guess but I do I do find that
more often than not it seems to work
it's not it's not exactly like okay this
block produced you know a 20 pound
improvement in my squat in the previous
block so it will produce another 20
pound improvement this time it's not
quite like that
but generally good results seem to get
you generally good results there is some
sort of shelf-life to it and I'm not
sure exactly what that is so it's
important like when I'm looking back
through these block reviews after a
while you collect a lot of them you know
so at what point do you start throwing
them out like okay well that that data
is two years old now you're not the same
lifter that you were two years ago at
least we hope not so at what point do we
start you know not considering those
things a year somewhere between a year
and two years seems to be a good idea to
me right now but that's not really based
on anything other than kind of my gut
feeling at the moment I would say now
that
since and just just one final question
how to what degree do different lifts
seem to respond similarly to similar
variables so like for example if you
find that your squat does really really
well with say high-intensity and
moderate volume do you find that that
also correlates with what bench and
deadlift respond well to or do those
seem to be just completely different
variables you need to figure out I have
if I found that your bench responded
best to high-intensity moderate volume I
would look there right away when it
comes to squatting and deadlifting but
it's also not uncommon to find people
that have different quirks so a couple
years ago I was working with Brett Gibbs
for the 2018 World Championship and what
we found with him was that his deadlift
responded great when we did low
intensity volume work so like 70% for
reps that's when his deadlift was at its
best and it responded moderately well to
like middle intensity zones and not that
great too high intensity
so we kind of reverse reverse pyramid
into the competition that year so his
second last block was in a middle
intensity zone his last block was the
lowest intensity that we had trained
that and it went great his bench on the
other hand was kind of the opposite
it really did well on high intensities
heavy singles but his was also kind of a
unique scenario that it didn't he wasn't
able to maintain that for for a really
long time so normally and I'll just kind
of caveat this with that's not normally
the case normally your time to peak is
the same for each of the three lifts you
know if you're 5 weeks to peak it's
going to be 5 weeks for the squat bench
and deadlift you know maybe one of them
is one week off from that
it seems to be pretty consistent Brett
was a strange case because his bench
only when we trained it at really high
intensities his time to peek on the
bench would get really short so I
remember needing to kind of switch into
a high intensity mid block for him but
that's how his bench responded best
that's again that's a unique scenario
that I wouldn't say that that's
everybody but again if that's youth and
that's gonna be important for you to
consider that's just not the first place
I would look that makes sense so as
people have talked about emerging
strategies more has there been any just
chatter about it or misunderstandings
about it that you would like to clear up
just so you know just to make sure that
when people talk about your concept of
emerging strategies they are actually
talking about what it actually is and
not just what they think it is I haven't
seen that much of what I would say is
like real misconceptions I mean maybe
maybe you have and I'm just not that
aware of things but yeah and seen a lot
of what I would consider misconceptions
that it seems like the idea of all the
lifts peaking having having a fairly
similar time to peak is counterintuitive
for a lot of people I find people expect
them to be different but they're usually
not and and I would even say that if you
have one that's really different the
first thing that I would look at is
maybe the training just didn't work that
great for the odd lifts so let's say
that you're squat and you're deadlift
peak in six six weeks and then the bench
seemed to peak in week three well that's
strange
and I would the first assumption I would
make is maybe that program just didn't
work that great for the bench and you
should try some different variables or
try to try something different for
versus assuming that you just have a
different time to Pete for the bench
most people that I work with they do
have very similar times the peak for for
all three competition lists that's
probably the thing that I would say
people misunderstand but the rest of it
I think I think a lot of people just
don't know that much about it yet and
the ones that do are finding unique
applications for it you know I've heard
of people who instead of adding weight
each microcycle or adding reps each
microcycle which that's not exactly how
I would run it but I mean try it and see
if it works you know the the neat thing
about it is that you can follow
athlete's response and if it gets you a
better response and you can show that in
some way then that's justified belief as
far as I'm concerned
Mike yeah this isn't really a question
it's more a comment but I really love
you know when you introduced this topic
you mentioned that a lot of people with
their fluctuation and training variables
they're you know they're cycling through
different intensities and cycling in and
out of different exercise selections and
at a certain point it's kind of hard to
tell you look back at this whirlwind of
just cycling variables and you're like
what the hell actually worked when you
look back at it I think that's one of
the things that a lot of people would
really benefit from you know is getting
I guess embracing this idea of having a
slower more methodical approach to
changing variables and training so you
know I work with clients who a lot of
times they'll be like when are when are
we going to drastically change this that
and the other thing all at the same time
and intuitively you're like well if we
change all of it how do we know what was
an effective change so like I said not a
question but it's one of those things
that this is a thing I've been talking
to many of my clients about recently as
this idea of
let's slow down and change these things
one at a time I think a lot of people
listening might benefit from this even
just the general concept of if you're
going to make these training changes try
to control the some number of these
variables so you can actually make some
solid observations over time yeah you
know I thought it kind one of the there
were a couple early observations for me
that helped me kind of get behind the
idea and one was that I don't really
think that having all the variables all
these interlocking cycles within cycles
and constant change I don't think that's
really necessary you know like it I
think if you had to simplify things as
much as possible without without losing
the effectiveness of the program how
much does does that constant change
improve your adaptation of the training
like I just can't think that it's all
that much you know so that was one of
the things and and I also remember kind
of being concerned that oh my my lifters
are going to get bored you know doing
the same training week over and over and
again there's probably a selection bias
in this but what I've noticed with my
own lifters is that I've had almost zero
problem with like boredom complaints and
it seems like at least for power lifters
if you're adding weight to the bar every
week then training is fun and then when
that stops and then it does eventually
stop now we're not having fun anymore
but also now it's time to change some
things you know and then we go into a
pivot and we've changed into a new
development block and so on and that's I
don't have the problems with boredom
that I anticipated in the beginning yeah
I mean I think you probably hit the nail
on the head when it comes to I would
think because you are such an appealing
coach for
high level power lifters you probably
run into it less than others but you
know for me I get a pretty even mix of
people who have very strengths oriented
and performance oriented goals and some
people that have more physique oriented
goals and I can tell you from the
physique oriented folks there's almost
this it seems like a prevalent thought
that if you're not changing you're not
trying you know it's it's we have to be
recycling everything at all times and
it's probably because you know Mike you
remember reading the old muscle
magazines and it's like what's 39 ways
to target my chest in a single workout
so you know that there are certain
subgroups within fitness that it's a
little bit harder to sell on this idea
where they say okay what do we change in
this week and it's like we just keep
getting better like if we change things
it might not be good for us but we got a
really good thing going and sometimes
that is a surprisingly difficult sell
yeah well not to veer too far off into
just coaching philosophy but you know we
talked about this this change and I get
asked a lot like what do I think the the
mechanism behind it is like why do I
think the change is meaningful why do I
think that it's helpful and I don't
really know the answer to it but I'd be
willing to bet that at least part of it
is attention that from a powerlifter
standpoint if I can get you engaged with
the training if I can get you paying
attention having fun even you know
looking forward to the training thinking
about it and then you go in there and
you execute it and you're feeling good
about it the weights are going up that's
good and that's that's positive I just
get this sense that that's making the
training more effective and when when
that momentum kind of runs out well if I
can change something and you know now
we're doing a new rep range and we're
doing a new exercise or something like
that and now you're paying attention
again
then even better you know whereas if you
do have a personality where you're like
look I don't really care that the weight
is five pounds heavier this week you
know I'm ready to do a different
exercise then that might matter as well
you know kind of getting that
psychological by in like that was
something that I heard coaches talk
about forever and it just didn't really
mean a whole lot to me until I would say
in the last couple years like I've
started to to kind of at least hope hope
I understand it a little bit better you
know and I place a lot more value on it
it's not just getting the athlete buy-in
but there's a certain enthusiasm that
you bring to the training then I think
makes a makes a real difference I agree
no I agree with that wholeheartedly as
well so Mike one question I wanted to
ask you and this is this is a huge
change of gears here so you are I would
say one of just a small handful of
people who has coached as many
world-class athletes as you have and so
you you would probably be in a better
position to to answer this question or
at least to muse about this question
than just about anyone so one of the
things that I'm interested by fascinated
in is like what like what eventually
stops people from progressing like like
why don't people just get bigger and
stronger forever and I don't so much
want to ask you about like maybe
mechanisms behind that but what are
signs you have seen if any in like in
yourself or maybe in some of your
athletes that are like potential signs
that the athlete is you know maybe
reaching the highest level of strength
development that they are ever going to
attain like have you seen any trends or
commonalities there that may provide
some sort of clue that an athlete is
Mearing or at their like quote-unquote
genetic limit and so you gotta take a
shot at me like that no I'm just you
know I mean this is truthfully something
I've been thinking about so my own
training I've been training trying to
get stronger for 22 years now yeah 22
years almost 23 and I mean this strength
is definitely a lot harder to come by
than it used to be I am kind of
eternally hopeful though like a having
like like you mentioned working with
high-level athletes I've not ever really
run into someone where I said you know
what I don't have any more ideas you
know there's always something that I
want to try or what if we try to to get
you to produce force this way or that
way I think a lot of by by that time in
a lifters career a lot of the technical
optimization is has been done you know
you can try to improve muscle mass you
can try to increase training volume but
that's a lot of times limited either
physically or you know just life
socially I guess you know but I think
that's what takes me back to trying
different exercises and what if we you
know you you tend to have a problem in
your deadlift with with this mechanic or
that mechanic like what if we
concentrate the workload and the energy
that we do have on fixing that problem
does that get us anywhere and I mean I
know this is kind of not answering the
question but I try not to I guess I kind
of have a never-say-die approach to it
so even if I've got a lifter who's
probably there you know like I'm
still looking I'm still kicking over
rocks and it's like look man probably
kicked over all the rocks but you know
I'm gonna I'm gonna keep checking until
until they've had enough I guess no I
got you that uh that makes a lot of
sense so one of the things you you
touched on there is you know by that by
that point in someone's training career
they've probably you know underwent all
of the technical optimizations that
they're going to what so I noticed you
had an article in your website from oh
maybe like a year ago about self
organizing technique which I actually
didn't see when it was published and I
just saw that like 20 minutes before we
started recording what I was trying to
to put some questions together so would
you mind just I I guess like briefly
talking about that concept the idea of
like universal quote unquote optimal
form and how you would go about making
technique changes for your athletes or
finding the ideal technique for a new
athlete well you remember a couple years
ago there was there were these
photographs that were circulating around
and they were femurs and pelvises and
they were showing like all the different
architecture of femurs and pelvises like
oh this person had really deep hip
sockets and this person had shallow hip
sockets and this person had a femur that
attached at this angle versus that angle
and so on that was kind of making the
rounds a couple years ago and I think it
kind of yeah kind of really highlighted
the anatomical differences like we know
certain things right like some people
have long legs or short legs long torso
short torso so we know stuff like that
but there's stuff that we can't see
going on as well and so like I'm working
with David Wilson now and David's got a
really wide squat stance and actually
that's all
one can never seem to talk about when he
posts the video like he's squatting
these ridiculous weights and this like I
would like guys it's just a wide stance
squat like let's talk about something
else you know but he's an example of
somebody who I think it's just kind of
found this technique it agrees with his
hips he's been doing it for a long time
and he's adapted to it like people are I
would say fearful a lot of times of
squatting with a stance like that or at
least you would think so based on
reading Internet comments but you know
if you've been doing it for years
you know it's probably fine you know you
adapt to those things I would say that
there are some things that I wouldn't
really want my athletes to adapt to and
you know if they were you know dead
lifting with a with a really rounded
back or certainly if they were lifting
with some technique that was against the
rules you know you've got to have a
conversation at that point so there
there are some things that I would still
say or
at least I'm not comfortable with but
outside of that I want them to try
different things and you know take note
oh it feels better when I lift this way
or that way and if there's something
that's grossly inefficient then you know
we'll try to try to adjust it but I
don't do it in a real top-down way and
probably my favorite example of that is
is the chest fall pattern and the squat
some people well most people actually
when the weight gets heavy enough as
they squat out of the bottom the hips
come up kind of out of proportion with
the shoulders you know and it kind of
when it gets really noticeable it looks
like a good morning squat but even when
it's not that bad it's a little bit of a
chest fall pattern I will try to give
lifters
exercises that teach them to do it
correctly so rather than cue them
repeatedly over and over I want them to
to have a different perceptual feedback
of that so if let's say that you're
having that problem I might assign pin
squats or safety bar squats something
that challenges you to maintain the
torso position and if you do it right
things are a little bit easier you can
use a little bit more weight and if you
do it wrong then things are harder and
you use less weight well power lifters
like to use more weight so it's kind of
a built-in feedback mechanism in the
lift itself which is really useful in an
online setting because I can't be there
and cue them every rep so kind of it
teaches you to feel it which is what you
need to do anyway so we try to do things
like that things like things bar paths
in the bench seems to be a pretty common
one as well trying to teach people to
get the bar back over the shoulders
early in the lift and and things like
that
all right so Mike the the last question
we have for you before we we wrap
everything up is just based on you know
what you see people talking about online
are there any coaching practices you
partake in or things you believe really
strongly that either go against what is
at least perceived to be the scientific
consensus or conventional wisdom in the
the strength and coaching world probably
the biggest one I'd be interested in
your thoughts on this as well I see a
value in overload work at least that's
kind of what we've come to call it and
I'm not quite sure that I can articulate
like a mechanism for it but I just see a
use for it so what I mean is
things like bands and chains slingshots
doing squats with knee wraps for people
who just compete in sleeves and and even
even more aggressive
like classic power lifting gear partial
ranges of motion all that stuff I am
willing to try it and usually I'm more
adventurous with it on the bench then
then the other lifts and probably
deadlift a second and squat as as last
but I I do try those things and I see
lifters again I get I wouldn't know what
to tell you is like the for sure
mechanism for how that's working but I
noticed that hey every time I put
slingshot bench in this in this guy's
program his bench gets better every time
we do deadlifts with chains or bit
deadlifts with bands it doesn't matter
which one
her deadlift goes up so yeah you know
it's one of those things that I'll see
people sometimes other coaches or just
people talk about how it's silly to do
those things and I think well okay maybe
it's silly but we do silly things and
our lips go up so I guess I'll keep
doing silly things right so that I
suppose that's probably the first one
that jumps to mind for me no I I got you
that uh I haven't I haven't noticed the
same thing really but there is some
level of precedent for it in the
research my I don't know this could be
completely wrong but my hunch is that it
might have to do with like bone and
connective tissue adaptation like I
think people I think people under 8 and
just underestimate how much cross talk
there is between muscle and connective
tissue and muscle and bone and
connective tissue and bone like there's
their signaling pathways that allow all
of those tissues to talk to each other
basically and there also seems to be a
reasonably strong relationship between
just how large someone's skeleton is and
how much bone mass they have and how
much muscle
they can eventually wind up with and so
I I wonder if I wonder if those things
are related and it's like you know once
you do enough conventional powerlifting
training you know it helps you build
more bone to a certain point and then
eventually it stops being effective like
you've you've essentially gotten all of
those adaptations you're going to but
then you know you really add a lot more
load into the mix and you can maybe like
stimulate some more osteogenesis like
that's that's a possibility I guess well
I I guess when what you could I guess
one way you could test that if you
didn't have if you didn't have access to
like a DEXA to directly assess it is you
could see whether overload work is more
effective for younger lifters versus
like masters lifters so you know if you
see that like pin squats and partial
deadlifts and slingshot bench really
help like younger lifters more
frequently but maybe not as much masters
lifters who probably you know can't
probably increase bone mineral density
to some degree but not as robustly as a
younger lifter could that might give
some some indication in that direction
I'd be interested to see that at least
you'd have to to look at actual numbers
and stuff and not just random punches
but my hunch is that it's probably
better for or I see it being effective
more often for experienced lifters like
I even had a one of our coaches mark
he swore up and down the reverse band
squats made his squad go up and I I've
just never been a fan of that movement
at all and you know reluctantly agreed
to include it and I'll be darn it it's
at least associated with improvements in
the squat for him you know that's he's
like the only guy that I've ever ever
had that experience with so no I mean
that that's definitely interesting one
of the things I've noticed and and this
could just be you know a matter of
athlete pool is that like power lifters
are obviously way better than
strongman competitors at squat and bench
press but like the elite strong men seem
to deadlift especially conventional
considerably more than the top power
lifters do wrong and like you know on
one hand there is more money in
strongman but on the other hand the
total athlete pool in powerlifting seems
to be in order of magnitude larger if
not more so you would think that there
would be some folks with genetics like
that filtering their way into
powerlifting but I think the numbers
don't really back it up and if you look
at the way strongmen train deadlift like
they do way more partials than we do so
I wonder if there's something to that
like I don't know what the mechanism is
but I I haven't noticed that with with
squat and bench really but but I have
seen deadlift partials be be pretty
effective for quite a few people yeah I
will say that it seems to be partials
least often I find like dead lifting
with chains or bands and benching with a
sling shot
occasionally chains or bands are
probably the most likely to work just on
a gross level I seem to remember that
you did a block oh it was probably a
long time ago now of I think partial
squatting I think you were using a yoke
to do some partial squats but I never
really heard how that worked out went
well for a couple weeks and then I had
you know my my 50th back injury like
four weeks into the block so hard to
know how it would have finished up yeah
no not because of that it was from yeah
I don't know probably just like bending
over funny or something yeah yeah
I should try that again though yeah that
was fun while it lasted run the
experiment I mean that's the that's the
other part of it right like I know that
you've followed bud Jefferies over the
years and I mean he's a guy that just
likes lifting heavy stuff you know and
will find ways to
heavy stuff and I think there's if it's
not like directly transferring I mean
there's something to be said for having
fun with your train for sure all right
Mike so that that brings us to the end
of the pre-prepared
questions we had for you and topics we
wanted to cover is there anything else
just currently that you are really
interested in or passionate about that
you know you just like to chat about and
share with the world I mean you guys hit
on the stuff that I seem to be spending
most of my time thinking about you know
what that is Mike that is extreme prep
work very diligent research on our end
so that's a human element I mean I think
you guys have a teen or something right
we have several interns that work around
their Lobby or no money yeah so so full
disclosure actually we were out of town
this weekend and my car just like
completely broke down and [ __ ] the bed
Thursday or Friday so I completely
forgot we were recording this until I
got a calendar notification 30 minutes
prior and Eric completely forgot we were
recording this until I told him about it
20 minutes prior so we actually are just
huge fans of the deep Mike to sheer lore
and these were questions pretty much
completely off the dome well I I do hope
that you know someday like once I'm once
I'm gone from this world that it'll be
something like like Tolkien you know
like people will continue to continue to
develop the storylines in my absence you
know I will say like Greg story is a
hundred percent true he found out 30
minutes pre and uh ten minutes later
told me about it but I remember at the
European powerlifting conference just
hanging around while the two of you guys
talked and legitimately having a good
time while saying nothing just kind of a
fly on the wall listening to you guys
chat about training so
for any other interview I would have
been like okay we're screwed but for
this one I was like yeah we're fine this
is gonna be fun and no it's been it's
been really fun listening to you guys
again and interjecting here and there
yeah well training is like the one thing
in my life that I can really monologue
on so I'll fill the space so Mike Weir
can work in people stay up to date with
you probably Instagram is the best best
way for me and it would just be my to
share on Instagram but we're also active
there through reactive training systems
and it's reactive training systems on
YouTube as well we're putting YouTube
videos out weekly then we do our own
podcast as well probably shouldn't say
that right but we do we do do a podcast
when we cross post that on YouTube most
of the time sounds good
well I think that does it for us so
thanks again for coming on I hope your
training goes well hope everything hope
everything else just goes well with you
from now until the end of time do you
have just any final thoughts you want to
leave the listeners with I really like
aliquots slogan strong is happy so I
guess that's my that's what immediately
comes to mind
awesome well Mike thanks so much for
coming on we've brought up your
impending death or at least alluded to
it twice I think already so we should
probably end the call before we before
we forthcoming death a third time right
no I said I said until the end of time
I'm implying that Ray Kurzweil
singularity is going to come and and
mecha Mike to shear is going to get
uploaded into the cloud and produce
world champions until the heat death of
the universe yeah it's it's just if you
read the transcript of this you would
think that Mike is a hundred and four
years old on his deathbed
these are his concluding remarks to the
world
alright well
in powerlifting terms it feels like that
sometimes I'm like guys I'm 34 I don't
know what to tell you like not even the
Masters lifter yet
alright well Mike once again thanks so
much for joining us everyone listening
thank you for tuning in and we will see
you in 2020 thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com2 check
out the products and services that we
offer thanks for listening and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you